the screams
and shout everyone here is very chic and
i was like am i chic enough to stay
glowing in yellow the bafta and critics
choice winner definitely fits the part
while wearing oscar de la renta i mean
that strut
taking a page from old hollywood glamour
lady gaga dazzles in a custom velvet
ralph lauren gown looking fresh off the
runway daniel kaluuya in prada and the
bafta looks keep serving naomi campbell
florence pugh sebastian stan and selma
hayek
and of course la kept it real at the
critic's choice with keisha i just heard
you were 12. yes
no
and i really like your boots you look
good you do too we have the same color
on we got the memo
am i wearing the same color because
yours is giving way more excitement
do we don't got to tell anybody the
secret's okay i just want to pose with
you i get to see you at first then you
look good
you too
okay now this is so cute joshua jackson
and jody turner smith are making sure
they're camera ready and our lady in red
miss selena gomez i mean stunning in
louis vuitton staying on the red theme
sandra bullock means business with her
blazer in austin texas while premiering
her new flick the lost city at south by
southwest it's been a long time since
i've laughed
other than at myself
and that was the whole journey of this i
have to respectfully decline i'm afraid
i must insist and in the most nicholas
cage movie ever mr cage describes what
it was like to play a fictionalized
version of himself for the unbearable
weight of massive talent the word that
comes to me is like it was a trip you
know to play
someone named nick cage and two versions
of someone named nick cage
it was
terrifying oh my god i love you